حسنًا، من المؤكد أن الأوكرانيين يشعرون
بالقلق بشأن بعض الأشياء التي
تحدث في الولايات المتحدة وخاصة
في الكونجرس هناك، وبالتأكيد
يعتمدون بشكل كبير جدًا على المساعدة الأمنية الأمريكية
وقد رأينا ذلك في ساحة
المعركة هنا في شرق
البلاد.  في الجنوب أيضًا إلى حد كبير من
جميع الجوانب، يبدأ الأمر بالبنادق
ويبدأ بالرصاص، ولكن بعد ذلك يكون لديك أيضًا
ذخيرة مدافع أكبر
وصولاً إلى أنظمة صواريخ أرض جو،
لذا فإن الولايات المتحدة هي أكبر مزود للأسلحة إلى حد بعيد.
الأوكرانيين الذين
يستخدمونهم بعد ذلك في ساحة المعركة، لذا فإن هذا
مهم جدًا بالنسبة لهم ولكن
هناك وجهًا ثانيًا لهذا أيضًا
وهو التأثير المخيف المحتمل
الذي يمكن أن يحدثه أي نوع من قطع المساعدة الأمنية الأمريكية
على شركاء الولايات المتحدة
الذين يقدمون أيضًا
هناك مثالان كبيران على الأسلحة إلى أوكرانيا، على
سبيل المثال، أعطى الألمان
أنظمة إطلاق صواريخ متعددة
للأوكرانيين، لكنهم لم يفعلوا ذلك إلا بعد أن أعطت الولايات المتحدة
أيضًا دبابات
قتالية رئيسية للأوكرانيين، وكذلك دبابات القتال الرئيسية التي
سمح الألمان لدول أخرى بإعطاء
دبابتين قتاليتين رئيسيتين ليوبارد.  وتفعل أوكرانيا
الشيء نفسه أيضًا، ولكن مرة أخرى فقط بعد
التوصل إلى اتفاق مع إدارة بايدن يقضي بأن تقوم
إدارة بايدن بتوفير
دبابات أبرام القتالية الرئيسية للأوكرانيين، ومن
المؤكد أن الأمر قد يكون صفقة ضخمة إذا
قررت الولايات المتحدة تقليص
مساعدتها الأمنية لأوكرانيا.  أو أوقفوا كل ذلك
معًا مرة أخرى، يدرك الأوكرانيون تمامًا
أن هذا أمر مثير للاهتمام للغاية
لأن المتحدث باسم
وزارة الخارجية الأوكرانية خرج اليوم محاولًا
وضع وجه جيد على الأمور قائلاً انظروا
في النهاية إلى أنه يأمل أن
يتمكنوا من العمل مع أوكرانيا.
إدارة بايدن للتأكد من أن أي
ميزانية مستقبلية ستكون مفيدة
لأوكرانيا فريد بلانكتون سي إن إن وشرق
أوكرانيا
وإذا فشلت الولايات المتحدة في إخراج ذلك من
الكونجرس ونقله إلى الأوكرانيين،
أليس هذا فوزًا لبوتين لا يعني
الكفالة  خارج فلاديمير بوتين، أعني أن
الأوكرانيين جعلوه في مواجهة
الحبال لبعض الوقت الآن، أعني أن كل هذا كان من
المفترض أن يحدث منذ أكثر من أشهر من
وجهة نظرهم في الكرملين،
وهذا سيأتي في الوقت المثالي
لفلاديمير بوتين وبوتين.  فقط أنقذه،
أليس كذلك، نعم، حسنًا،
كنت سأذهب خطوة أبعد
من ذلك، أه جيم، أود أن أقول إن ذلك
كان بالفعل فوزًا لبوتين
وأولئك الذين يفكرون مثله، فقد رأوا
الاضطراب والخلل الوظيفي  في
حكومتنا بعدة طرق أه هذا هو
الأحدث فقط، لذا فهم
مستمرون في استخدام هذا الشعار بين بعض
حلفائنا ليقولوا إن الولايات المتحدة
لا يمكن الاعتماد عليها، ويجب ألا تثق
بهم كحلفاء لك، ويجب أن تثق بنا،
وفي الواقع، هذا هو  قد يمنح السيد بوتين وأنا
متأكد من ذلك لو كنت زعيمًا سياسيًا
لقلت أن هذه
فرصة مثالية لمواصلة محاولة
تمديد هذا الصراع أه أكثر فأكثر
وسيكون الأمر صعبًا ولكن
أعتقد أن جزءًا من جهود السيد بوتين  الاستراتيجية هي
جعل هذا الصراع مجمداً كما
فعل في أربع دول أخرى في أوروبا، لذا
نعم أعتقد أن هذا يساعده بالتأكيد
ولكن أعتقد أن الأهم من ذلك أنه يظهر
للعالم أن هناك أوقات
لا يمكننا الاعتماد عليها لأننا "  إعادة
الميل نحو المستبدين والديكتاتوريين